what's up ann how are you doing i have a
24 year old young man
who lives with um his dad my husband who
um who i believe is addicted to
pornography
your son is yes and he lives in your
house
yes okay tell me about how that works um
i have evidence of of money coming out
of his account anywhere from five to
twenty dollars
that kind of i traced back um i've told
him like to give me
his phone which he does a couple of
evenings but then
a couple evenings have passed and he
doesn't give me my phone because we go
to bed early because we get up very
early
um he follows girls on instagram he sits
in a common area when i walk by and what
are you doing
um ryan he'll quickly turn the picture
to something else i do have a younger
child
21 living at home so i'm really
concerned that he's picking up on it
he is he doesn't take care of himself
and why is he living at home he's 24 i
know
well that's the problem and that's why
i'm calling you because it's getting in
the way
of my husband and i relationship
absolutely
i i'm kind of like if i warn him and i
put it out there
let him let him go and my husband is
saying he needs help let's keep him here
and direct him and get him help
what does he need help what does he need
help with um we feel like there's
depression there
he stays he'll stay in his room he
doesn't eat unless it's served for him
or he'll order in
all the time do you hold on hold on hold
on do you serve it
um on the on the on the counter before i
go to bed because
i guess i'm a concerned mom and he will
not eat like he's no no no no you're not
a concerned mom
you're not you're not i'm an enabler
yeah you are
you are getting what you need by taking
care of your little boy
and you've got he has no problems he has
no reason to change
anything in his life at all he's got it
so
good he has food put on the counter
he's got no rent he's got women just
piped into his phone
that challenge him in no ways he's got
money just going from his account
straight he can do whatever he wants
whenever he wants to
and what that leads to is
deep resounding depression
because there's no there's no goal
there's no achievement there's no
working towards something there's no
little steps there's no
success there's no internal esteem that
can only be accomplished not from
telling you someone you're great
but from doing things you've got to go
do and this young man is just drowning
because mom keeps putting water in the
in the bathtub
he's got to have some problems he's got
a great life right now
okay so how can we help him then kick
him out
say go or say
you will go see a counselor you will
have no phone in my house
when there will be zero phones none
and then when we go to bed the internet
goes off and i take the router in my
bedroom
it's out because
if you're not serious about it you're
not serious about it
he's 24.
people you're how old are you anne 55
yeah i have i have two other children i
have a total of four children
ranging from 21 to 27.
what does your 27 year old think about
him just living at home
probably a lot of the same things i'm
telling you too
is he does he have like mental illness
is he struggling have real
like significant challenges um i would
say along the lines of depression
self-esteem
for sure um and he doesn't he doesn't
seem to care like
he leaves his room is filthy i will help
help
help him clean him up and he'll go right
back to his old ways he leaves his
in and out burger bag all in the living
room of common area after i've told him
to pick it up
i know i know but do you hear what
you're saying as you say it out loud you
hear it i know you do
i do because it doesn't matter he can do
whatever he wants in his room because
his mom's gonna help him come clean it
i'm embarrassed for myself if i have his
other siblings come over to visit us
or friends come over so what is it about
him
i don't want to tell you to kick a guy
out with severe mental illness
if he's schizophrenic if he's bipolar if
he's got some major challenges
if anything depression and i and i've
asked him to see the doc
to see a doctor i can't make it for him
he's 24. he says
he denies having a problem well cool go
get him buddy you got two months left
and you're gonna have a job and you're
out
i will change the locks and you're not
doing this because you're mean you're
doing this because you love your son
or let me let me let me put it this way
you're giving him everything in
because you love him you really do and i
believe that
is it anything you're doing helping him
no no is anything getting better
definitely not okay so you got to do
something different
you can't keep doing the same thing
wanting the same outcome
right correct yeah
and either it's cold turkey you got
you got 60 days and you're gone or
it is if you're gonna live here starting
in 60 days you pay
rent or i will evict you and well
he does pay me rent he pays me 425
dollars
does he work phone uh he does four to
five days a week
it's for his phone his cell phone story
in the groceries and his car insurance
so 425 barely and then the food what
what is he worth amazon amazon delivery
so he's out making deliveries correct
so what's he do with the rest of his
money just saves it uh he's a saver
we are dave ramsey followers so i will
tell you i've taught him in that respect
and he's really excited about that
but uh hey you know why he gets excited
because it's actual achievements
accomplishment it's things he can see
progressing in his life in a positive
direction
his social life he's not seeing that his
ability to create his own wealth he's
not seeing that
because he's got no home he's got no
equity he's got no things he's working
towards
career advancement he's got nothing
there
oh i agree and he's gonna tell you
you're the worst mom
ever he's gonna tell you you guys are
ruining my life i can't believe you're
kicking me out unbelievable after all
you've done and all
you know that's coming and that's going
to be part of the separation but until
he has any sort of struggle or
any sort of reason to do anything in his
life differently he's not going to
i wouldn't
right what's your husband think about
this is your husband ashamed or does he
like it
um no he says that we should help him by
keeping me in our house and direct them
in
certain ways but uh how is the direction
helping what does your husband say
i'm hard um he needs help my husband
struggles with depression so he sort of
feels knows how it feels to feel
the self-esteem and lack of self-esteem
yeah mm-hmm have you ever gone to a
family counselor before
no never yeah maybe you should try that
because y'all got to develop some pretty
hard boundaries real real fast
and you got a 21 year old soaking all
this in
so what your 21 year old is is learning
is that mom and dad have no boundaries
and they're gonna it's a they're a gravy
train for whatever i want to do
so i know you're worried about them
learn your 21 year old learning about
how pornography works like spoiler alert
he's known that probably since he was 10
or 11. how that works
he's learning how to navigate the adult
world right now
that's what he's learning and it has
zero consequences
mom will yell and she'll get mad and all
you have to do is change the screen
and she'll eventually clean your room
and pick up the food bags
and if she doesn't do that she's gonna
make food and put on the counter for us
before she goes to bed
and so what i want you to do anne is you
are gonna have to learn to love
differently because the way you're
loving your kids right now
is not helping them it's harming them
it's drowning them and they have to
learn how to swim
they've got to got to got to got to god
to learn how to swim
my uber recommendation would be to get a
family therapist who would come visit
you at your house
or you demand the entire crew everyone
living in that house
is going to see somebody together and
that you announced to your husband and
to your
your kids i'm making boundaries
you've got 60 days to get out you've got
30 days to get out
depend if he's got a bunch of savings
he'd get out tomorrow he's got to go get
an apartment
and his apartment's going to be the most
disgusting gross thing you've ever seen
and that would be his choice and he may
go down a
rabbit hole of pornography
and dysregulation and hopefully he will
see the light take care of himself begin
working towards things
you can start exercising with him you
can do all kinds of things that are
going to
be productive loving behavioral changes
in his life
but just letting him exist like a
like a like a plant that you're just
gonna water and feed and yell at but i'm
just gonna keep watering if you
it's not doing many favors he's gonna
have to get some problems he's gonna
have to learn some new muscles and he's
gonna have to grow
up and i know you love him and these are
the hard choices you gotta make he's 24
years old he's a grown man
if he'd been in world war ii he'd
already would have gone to war been back
and married and probably have three kids
right he'd ever be back
he'd already have seen the world it's
time for him to grow up all right anne
and it's time for you
to cut those codependent strings on both
of your kids and let them grow up and be
adults